so it's it's a really pleasure to be
here it's been an exciting two days so I
actually sat many times on your side of
the table so actually I said sort of way
way in the back usually because then I
could view of the room and actually I
you know I always enjoyed to the
presentations a lot but I always
wondered about a Microsoft products I
was wondering you know what is there in
the product vision that we don't know
about and therefore I thought what I'll
do today is I'll start a little bit with
the product that I'm working on which is
Microsoft teams and then I'll talk a
little about the challenges that we have
in building it and some of the challenge
that I see going forward and how we as
computer scientists will work in the
future
let me start with a short video over the
last few years we've seen how digital
transformation has shaped a new culture
of work from cubicles and silos to
collaborative workspaces
from rigid hierarchy to more flexibility
openness and inclusion from individual
achievement to teamwork and shared
success from limited data to boundless
information and insights as the stakes
get higher we're expected to be more
creative to get more done with less and
to deliver results faster at the same
time digital technology continues to
advance in exciting ways and a new kind
of workplace is emerging an intelligent
workplace where AI anticipates our
why's our tasks and
Jen's our capabilities
and we at Microsoft believe this new
technology is not just for Joseph you
but for every person in every
organization empowering each of us to
work together across teams across
countries and across languages meeting
and exceeding new demands
this is the future of work an
intelligent workplace for everyone so
let me talk a little about this in the
context of office 365 which is sort of
the application that I know Moore's so
if you think about digitalization what
it allows us it allows us just to do
more but also create more so in office
we have about 180 million monthly active
users and they actually set up about a
billion meetings every month they create
billions of documents every month and
sort of with this flood of content we
actually have to have ways of organizing
it of sifting through it then finding
out what's important devoting time to
that then in passing it on to the next
person the collaboration and so what
we've also seen is that not only the
studio dilation is driving massive
massive amounts of data is that the
modern workplace is changing itself so
if you look at how organizations are
working mobile and social tools are much
more prevalent than before so while half
of the workers they now use social tools
at work we see over the last four five
years that workers have or employees
have four times as many devices per user
than before
I mean there's some users that just live
directly on this kind of device and it's
also a little bit of a generational
thing and that means if you look at our
workforce becomes much more diverse and
global so there are studies that say
they claim they have five generations
together now for the first time in the
workplace that sounds a lot to me but
even if I look at jobs but even if I
look at sort of my teams they're
definitely globally diverse in that I
work with teams in Vancouver and you
know on the on the west coast but I also
work with teams in Prague augustine's in
Tallinn I work with teams in Oslo so I
work with teams all across the world and
they're both cultural differences and
and then they're also of course
differences in time zones and then of
course team dynamics is also changing so
every worker is now on average on twice
as many teams and about eighty percent
of the time they ever spend
collaborating so what we've done is
we've designed this product Microsoft
teams that anybody actually get a chance
play lived with it whoo-hoo got a check
okay a few people at least so I'll be
fast so Mike's of teams is basically the
new hub for in after excessive 65
they've designed basically address these
these challenges so it does is it allows
you to connect the dots so first of all
as you think about meetings the meaning
is not an isolated piece of your
workplace it's something that weaves in
the information fabric of your whole
digital life
so therefore what we've made sure is
that in Microsoft teams we can actually
work not in silos across apps but we
actually we've all the office apps into
your single surface there's actually a
great book by Patrick Lencioni called
death by meaning as anybody anybody's
read this book so so Paragon shown is
actually one of my favorite authors he
writes these business fables and so in
this book and what he talks about is he
talks about meetings and there's a whole
story around it
and then he comes to the conclusion that
meetings are usually not effective and
they're boring and and so we're trying
with teams actually address at least one
of them namely they're not boring
because they actually have all the
context not years they actually once you
have the right contact context then mean
exactly effective for boring what
Lencioni says is well you have to have
drama and you know we're working on that
a little bit more then of course want to
be inclusive right that people who have
lots of different ways of interacting
maybe chat maybe email maybe
face-to-face that they can be included
and then of course we want to work as a
team and this notion of going to achieve
and to a people centric notion of work
is actually I'm making through all of
our apps there's actually quite a
different way of thinking how office 365
works right if you think about over 365
you think about Word Excel PowerPoint
right you think about all these
different apps but you don't think about
people at the center of it but if you
think about teams and actually how a
reorganizing and connecting all of our
apps we're putting people at the center
of the work okay I'm very very quick on
this but this is teams
it's basically hard for teamwork in
office 365
the first capability is simple simply
communicate so you can have one-on-one
chats you can have open chat in channels
there in teams you can very easily have
meetings and kind of all the collateral
meetings together you can call you can
very easily have a one-on-one chat and
escalate in a call or of course you can
set up meetings in which you have
calling as well you can very easily
collaborate so in a chat you can
actually embed office documents you can
directly open them in the app and then
you can directly collaborate in the
office documents directly in the flow of
your work it's customized and extendable
so we understand now that people don't
only use Microsoft tools so what you can
do with teams is you can basically take
all of the other tools and integrate
them directly deeply into the app so it
has about more than 150 extensions and
there's all the whole developer platform
in which you can extend the app and then
of course you know given that as
Microsoft it has all the necessary
Enterprise controls but also the
security and compliance building from
the get-go actually what were also doing
is we're doing some interesting work
with devices this is actually an
interesting than we're not just taking
our devices and slapping teams on device
after device after device but we think
of these devices and as an intelligent
edge I don't know if any of you had
problems with setting up a meeting where
actually everybody has a cell phone and
a bunch of devices with cameras in the
meeting room and it's really hard to set
up this meeting because they don't all
know about each other
so with teams who are thinking about as
the intelligent edge that these devices
know about each other and then enable
very different kind of meeting
experiences when the edge actually is
connected together I want to talk about
one more aspect of the product is namely
that it's not only for the generic
information worker but as you know the
future of work changes and the nature of
work that people are doing is changing
we try to address different subgroups
and create tools that directly fit into
that workflow so one of the really am
big communities out there is first line
worker so these are the people that are
first engaged with customers they
represent a company's brand the
see the products and services in action
this is basically the airline
representative who helps you to rebook
your ticket if you have a problem this
is the barista at Starbucks who always
seems you know friendly and always
engaging this is the person at a retail
store who makes you comfortable when you
go into the retail store or who
basically you know checks you out at the
cash register so these are the people
who you directly interact with and as a
company they represent your brand and
it's actually often the blind spot doing
all of these digital transformation
efforts that we now have it's estimated
to be a population about 1.5 billion
workers and the daily activities tend to
be a lot of what we talk about here in
the summit maybe there had to be micro
tasks there maybe very task force if ik
but require the integration of lots of
different technologies and if you look
at the first line workers technology
needs they are about digital
communication task management scheduling
then integration of lob apps which is
basically the integration of other tools
in their workflow and then also access
to documents so let me play one other
video about how we're working with
first-line workers we base our work
culture very much on the Alcoa values
which is operate with excellence act
with integrity and the one that I care
about the most which is care for people
we open it 24 hours a day 365 days a
year we have to know what just happened
what was happening yesterday we have to
know what's happening tomorrow
communication was not as good as it
could be our announcements were coming
through email if I wasn't at work I
didn't see it it was a challenge to make
sure everybody got the messages it was
like shouting out into the void
sometimes a lot of the challenge is
trying to get the correct amount of
people foreign ship with the magnetic
port you have to physically be there to
try to get received this port was very
inefficient
the goal was connecting everybody and
teams was the tool we found for this it
has helped us a lot and a better one I
just go on my phone I see what ships are
open click on the shift and request it
it's really easy being able to use that
on a mobile phone is amazing it's truly
amazing and then at the end of every
shift
we write our shift messages for the next
one we use emojis and gifts it doesn't
have to be all seriousness can be fun
tips has allowed me to respond to the
people immediately we want everybody to
be heard and we want everybody to be
equal we're giving everybody a voice
vodka was moving forward with each
generation and our generation all have
phones in their pockets so teams is the
future
[Music]
okay great so now that you sort of have
a bit of an of an idea of what the
product does let me go through a couple
or two or three features and then let me
dive a little bit down into the
technology that actually is there let me
use to create the product so throughout
the product we actually use a lot of
machine learning especially deep
learning so here's one simple example hi
for the couch the coffee stand is too
high for the couch hit the floor with a
crash the set of China hit the floor
with a crash so you clearly see the
difference between the two different
types of all of your heart let me move
on another thing that is that we hear
all the time from our users is that they
work in open environments and especially
now these days with offices move working
more in open space background noise is a
big issue so let me give you an example
here and this is with background noise
suppression and actually I'll come back
to that because that's actually an
interesting problem another thing that
we did is we looked at the whiteboard
that's designed for remote meetings you
probably have done this when you had a
collaborator at a different University
and what do you do at some point in time
things get excited and then you go to
the whiteboard and once you've worked on
the whiteboard the remote collaborators
usually disconnected from what you
actually do so what do you do you take
up your cell phone you take a picture of
the whiteboard and as the whiteboard
involves maybe you send a few more
pictures and there's actually a bunch of
good apps out there I mean even
Microsoft has one called office lens
which basically takes the picture and
then automatically crops shortens and
enhances it and straightens it and sends
it over and what we've basically done is
we've taken in collaboration with MSR
we've basically made the same ideas that
the picture basic your automatic
beautifies itself but then we added you
know some simple deep learning based
segmentation to filter out the person
that's blocking the whiteboard and the
result is maybe what you get on the
bottom right where it basically still
see the person in front of the
whiteboard and you know for remote
people in real-time and you can see sort
of what's in front of the person only is
revealed when the person you know moves
we're still working on trying to see
through persons as they're writing so
let me talk a little bit about the
technology that's underlying all of this
so first of all we're relying very
heavily on what we call global media or
delivery network which is a hundred
thousand miles of fiber you know fast
private fire across the globe that
Microsoft is using we have you know over
100 edge nodes which basically places us
much closer to our users with about
2,700 ISP peering relationships that
allow us to look at performance based on
traffic even down to the level of the
ISP what this means is they're actually
for about more than 6% of the GDP of the
world we are 25 milliseconds away so
let's think about audio/video right we
have seen a bunch of audio/video
examples now you let's actually dive
into the audio/video stack of teams in
Skype this was all new for me actually
so because I'm as you may know I work on
database systems so this was actually a
great learning experience for me and so
if you look at the an audio/video stack
right there's basically the data plane
on the top where you capture encode and
send and then receive and decode and I'm
being a little bit abstract here and
then the bottom you have the control
plane very easily capture then you do
rate controlling quality controlling and
bandwidth estimation so the interesting
thing is that this is actually quite a
complex scenario this has to work across
a wide variety of different types of
networks you know from 2g all the way up
to LAN and you know a variety of
platforms of course windows Android you
know iOS the right variety of hardware
like we talked about the intelligent
edge it cannot only work on smartphones
and PCs as the work and a wide variety
of embedded devices as well and then of
course you know taking power conditions
into account I mean if I'm if my phone
is running low on battery you know I
want to behave differently than if I'm
fully charged and so if you look at the
threads that part of the stack down here
you know it's only at least 150 thousand
lines of code right if I'm not too
generous it has about a thousand Hanshin
parameters and you know maybe some of
them were tuned with a be tests the
evolved over the last 15 years so
there's a lot of expertise a lot of the
main knowledge of networking experts in
coding at core tech experts and
everybody a lot of PhDs actually build
this piece of code and so the process
what we're doing right now is we're
trying to replace this red part with a
screen part so basically we're taking
the red boxes and replace it with a
magic green box no that's nothing really
is right but we're doing is we can
replace the whole control plane
basically with a model and now this
model gets all the inputs and gets all
the makes all decisions Amy what it
should be doing is we should actually
place everything with a model right why
why stop at the control plane maybe we
should do the whole data plane replace
it with the model and actually I see
some nodding from the audience here
sounds very logical and as you know so
this actually now changes quite the game
in which we work right on the left hand
side we have a lot of code you know on
the right hand side we have a much
simpler architecture and hopefully we
have no more hands-on parameters on the
left hand side near all this learning
concept free that's now encoded in the
code was done by developers in the added
new code and rules on the right hand
side there no hard-coded rules anymore
everything is automatically learn from
data on the left hand side we have a lot
of experts they're experts in networking
and codecs with a steep ramp up time
your people did their PhDs on this on
the right hand side we are sort of much
more fungible people and we have people
who need busy expertise and machine
learning deep learning and reinforcement
learning and on the left hand side
basically also when you have new
networks or new codecs then we need to
write new code and new rules I need to
write exceptions on the right-hand side
well maybe we just need to collect it a
little bit more data and retrain the
models everything is done right that's
that's how every paper would be written
right now and actually just I'll tell
you a little bit what what's the
difference to a paper in a second but
basically this is now called software to
dough as many of you know and we're in
the left hand side you see a program
with code and on the right hand side
your program with code data and Maltz
well in the left hand side you have
domain expertise in the right hand side
you have male expertise you transpire
the expertise to code or you collect
data code complex it down is
transferred into Data + search which
gives us once the left-hand side gets
better with more code or smarter people
the right-hand side gets better
hopefully with more data the left-hand
side is potentially hard coded and
brittle and the right hand side just
adapts with more data and learns the new
conditions and really what I do is very
different on the left-hand side a write
code on the right inside I probably need
to write some code as well ready to
write some framework code to make
everything working but but really what I
do on the right hand side is unlabeled
data so the interesting thing is that
this is not only a chain a way and
change north you know I'm moving to
machine learning but we need such ange
in process right so if you think about
it a high-level on the left hand side
you know I release define some task
design modules then have some release
mechanism you know write and reuse code
then I did bark and then I release and
the write inside okay i defined the task
as well then i collect data and labels
and sexually and major major tasks then
i prepare the data and train the model
is actually another major task and then
I did bark release and so on and this is
actually a very different process than
the process on the left-hand side all
right there's a model that I have there
on the left-hand side the code that I
used to write yeah we're trying to prove
properties about this code we're trying
to make this code as deterministic as
possible that we can prove correctness
of a program and we can write
specification of Prague's and then
directly translate them into code on the
right-hand side now I have this model in
there
Wow is it's like a doctor that I'm
treating a patient right I sort of have
to hop this model to actually understand
whether it's performing well where it's
performing well or not and sort of much
more of a scientist on the right-hand
side then on the left-hand side an
engineer so I want to tell you two
stories where I've actually seen this
shift towards data-driven decision
making some models in there directly
here there are correctly experienced one
of them was in a startup that I water
and the other one is here at Microsoft
so the starter was called a fast search
and transfer actually was two of my
colleagues formerly at Cornell they
introduced me and and then we we worked
there it was basically a search and
business intelligence
company and so we have clients such as
you know in finance ecommerce government
in retail they'd clients such as
Washington Post Nordstrom Marriott and
so on the main point is what we were
selling Enterprise Search so stiffer
from internet search where Enterprise
Search basically captures everything
that is inside of your company and I
mean there are people who have worked a
lot on Enterprise Search as he sue here
I there are lots of experts here but
basically Enterprise Search is very
different from internet search in two
different reasons to two main reason
there are a bunch of others the main
reasons that they're very few links and
so the link structure I mean John is
here right with Hopson Authority so the
linkster that's being used to actually
rank or get get strong signals in the
web is not there in the enterprise the
same thing is there very few clicks
because I might have a company that a
60,000 employees but still has a billion
documents right so the amount of
engagement that you have the
click-through rate because not on a
single global corpus is also very
different and of course at that point in
time our semantic understanding of
documents was much lower because we
didn't have you know all the cool Dina
and embeddings and so on that everybody
uses right now know if you look at
Enterprise Search it's really powered by
the power of data so what we can do is
actually this is when I joined Microsoft
for the second time in 2013 we build
what's called delve in the office graph
and then what the office graph basically
is it basically makes all the signals
that belong to a company available
through a programmatic API so we
basically if collected all the signals
across office 365 and made them
available as a data assets so look at
the office graph up there it's called
another Microsoft craft so we have a
user we have chats calendar messages
files groups etc etc so specially what
this means is suddenly now through
people in their interactions with
content the action has signals or
indirect signals and documents and so
what we cannot do is we can now actually
change first of all the way we discover
content by looking at an entity centric
way of discovering for example you can
use people as a hero entity and this is
an application that we built called l4a
basically go to a person and then
there's a relevant feed of relevant
content around that person base based on
all of these signals in addition we can
now use all of these signals as well
to make enterprise search much better so
this story number one story number two
is actually going back to Skype and
teams let me talk actually about an
application directly here which is just
capture quality enhancement it's the
same picture with the same colors right
on top we have now our sort of a little
bit simplified voice capture quality
pipeline right so you start off with
analog gain control then use an echo
cancellation then you do noise
suppression you have a voice activity
detector then you have key type
suppression they have digital gain
control and afterwards here's some
howling some echo suppression so we're
doing is again we're taking a bunch of
these red boxes and replacing with a
green box and by the way there's an
interesting question right there's
compensation that comes out of software
one dot oh and should we keep the same
compensation in software to at all or
should we just collapse everything into
a single model so what do you do now is
we can basically train this green model
well so how do we do this is very simple
well they just take noisy data as just
clean plus noise and we can generate a
lot of data like that and then we
minimize noise - clean right or minimize
some other objective function and a lot
of other approaches right we can do
universal we can learn the noise through
again or we can do a source separation
approaches so this is just an example of
the kind of work that we're doing and
maybe we think we can actually get
significantly better noise reduction
with this your curiosity went happily
out of bounds
dear curiosity what happily out of
bounds near curiosity went happily out
of bounds so this is always you know
noisy then with the existing tech and
then with a deep learning so this is
battle noise let me do one other one and
there's eternity with no time for
recommendations
so basically heard that was busy no
difference between the first and the
second and the reason is that there's
basically a Wiener filter in the current
algorithm that basically sort of takes
out gotta noise and Gaussian noise and
peerless chips transient ranching is not
Gaussian noise
okay so actually the interesting thing
is what we did is and we didn't only
learn to the noise suppressor actually
we sort of look one step ahead namely
what we did is we trained actually a
model that looked at the output of an
audio call and we trained a model that
could actually directly assess the
quality of the call at any point in time
so be easy think of this sometimes at
the end of a Skype call you've probably
seen this one of these call quality
feedback tools pops up you know how was
the call so think what we busy have done
is we've basically created there's no
reference order quality predictor which
basically listens into a call on your
client site completely private to you
but it can constantly give now a
thumbs-up thumbs-down how is the call
and that can now be used to actually
then even this model cannot be used to
train the noise suppressor which then
goes in and suppresses the noise and
actually sort of this replacement off of
code and you know with with these models
is not happening in all the areas of
computer science right the whole summit
was full of this right one of the areas
that I know a little bit about is
database systems and you know in Stata
systems actually happening all over the
place right there's the query optimizer
of course and selectivity estimation so
people have looked into but there'll be
other areas like core optimization query
rights together right I'm selective
estimation already mentioned they'll be
if you do corrupt emulation already why
not optimize the physical layer right
away as well right why not look at
resource management overall and delivery
system in general it's again you can
think of this like the control plane of
the nativist system can be replaced with
a model as well right so basically the
importance of like traditional
approaches will sort of shrink and the
approach the importance of other
approaches will grow over time okay
let's go back to background noise
suppression so what did we actually do
well we did all of these steps right you
created synthetic data did some ground
truthing create some reference data
created some German trained in the
German right and then a be test and
repeat so actually these steps are
common to most machine learning projects
and what's interesting is that train the
models there instead
right you define the data and if I data
sources create collect data define some
tests for data calibration define data
unit tests build a gym then you train
the model you depart and prove the model
will deploy the model wanted to collect
more data and repeat and every time you
know we interview candidates they're
most excited about seven right this is
where all the excitement's when you when
you look at papers you know the
improvements are always here this is so
super important really exciting however
if you look at where actually the time
is spent right the time is not spent on
step seven all right the time is spent
on all the other steps so actually less
than ten percent you know on the product
that I have done less than ten percent
of the time is spent on seven actually
we're getting very good in seven and
we're creating all ml right we have
architecture search we have lots of high
performers or search algorithms so so
while trading the model is fun right
you're spending huge amount of time on
all the other steps around it right and
again sort of if you talk with
candidates right there again excited
about training the model right do you
understand well should you use real OSH
what is the number of convolution layers
right the initialization should be this
the learning rate should be this wide
what should be the learning rate decay
be over time right should I use an l1 or
l2 norm right every all the steps that
we're as researchers are excited about
because we can technically quantify that
here's another thing I love step seven
because I can basically automate it
through differentiation it's so
basically this step here
there's a procedure behind it and then
it gets completely automated what I
would love to do actually is I would
have to take all of these steps
differentiate across all of these steps
together and unfortunate can't do this
yet right because we haven't made enough
progress to actually take all these
steps together okay so going back to
this to the change in process so
actually when a short is a slide I sort
of lied a little bit right and I was
sort of not telling you all the details
of
versus too narrow so actually let's look
at one that oh in a little bit more
detail so the way to think about
software actually the software welding
process in one not oh there are actually
two different cycles there's the inner
cycle which is basically you know you
add and write some code we then build it
in debug it think of this is just me
working you know on my PC or on my
laptop and basically working for me
myself then there's a whole outer cycle
the outer side is basically now where I
work together as a team and this outer
cycle it's super important there's a ton
of tooling around us right so let's
start out basically by I you know now I
check in now the code gets reviewed as a
review code then there's testing there's
a continuous integration pipeline
there's a release management process
there's monitoring there's issue
management there's documentation there's
analytics which actually shows me where
the a/b tests were correctly or correct
or I had any impact so actually the
pipeline in software will not oh you
know we call it computer science but
this is really software engineering so
this is really an engineering process so
it really done is we've basically taken
all the steps that you've made and
basically made an engineering discipline
and that's why companies such as
Microsoft and we can scale software
products and projects up to like hundred
plus developers otherwise we couldn't
effectively collaborate so so what's
actually not changing right so if I look
at one at all
well I have a traditional program tree
right this is sort of a stack trace here
now into Natal basically I replace some
of these boxes you know maybe with a
learned function maybe with a deep net
maybe with a deep net and some human
code maybe some guardrails right and I
could do that right for a regular
program I can of course do the same
thing for data stream program where I
directly you know go from data to some
action and the difference is basically
that on the left hand side in one dot or
basically give all this tooling around
it to have made this basically a
production pipeline into an engineering
discipline and so I would argue that on
the right hand side you know we are
starting to get some tooling we're
starting to learn more
still very much in our infancy so let me
talk for a few minutes about this high
level abstractions okay so this is like
computer science undergrad knowledge
rightly we have learned a lot about how
to hide complexity from the developer I
know whether anybody went to the talk
what we did about what we're doing
Visual Studio right and the visual
studio is an amazing tool for example
the interactive feedback is actually
amazing the sender is highlighting of
course the code Auto completion right
which is actually really interesting as
well but we have all the way from like
high level memory manage languages you
know declarative languages I actually
love at sequel it's actually the most
successful parallel programming language
I believe you know then then we have
ways to hide a synchrony right we have
future promises and another synchronous
programming support even Calton code
refactoring where actually the process
of refactoring is hidden from the
programmer and so on you know this
probably an incomplete list but on the
software to natal site if you the list
you know there it looks like research
projects there that we have right we
have machine teaching right and we
talked about machine teaching here at
the summit as well but I think it still
needs quite a way to go before it's an
engineering discipline right we have C
week supervision and you know Chris
talked about snorkel and and how it's
being started to be used I would say
it's often not yet really at an
engineering discipline level and we have
all ml and model selection hydrometer
tuning maybe that hides a lot of the
complexity of building the model
actually maybe we have separate data
engineers data scientists and male
engineers and maybe ml applied data
scientists so we are sort of starting to
branch on different sub disciplines and
but I don't think we have the final
answer yet here we have some free trade
models right bird and gp2 and so on it's
very easy to implement important to me
to enter Python and and other other
tools so I think we're getting there in
terms of we're making good good progress
but we're by far not as far as on the
left-hand side another interesting
question of course is debug ability in
debugging in general
so debugging is of course about
diagnosing fixing errors and other
underserved behavior right on the left
hand side we actually have really good
support in the debuggers breakpoint
stock tracer that's right we have quote
analysis tools we have log analysis
tools with anomaly detection you have
called DF tools where you can
collaborate with somebody else and work
on it you know on the right hand side
you know where or on the bottom here
we're getting there right I mean just I
think this comic actually explains it
well right is your machine right is this
your machine this is your machine
learning system yep
you pull the data into this big pile of
linear algebra and then collect the ants
on the other side well what if the
answers are wrong you just stir the pile
until they start looking right right so
basically while again in soft and 100
this is much more of an engineering
discipline it's much more for science
and maybe even a little bit of an art
right now and to train models that have
the right performance and get the right
pipeline right there's one other
interesting question and I think that
section open recent question maybe this
is the whole notion of debugging and
explaining for code we know how to do
this right so soon I can sit here
together we can look at this program and
understand where the bacchus does
anybody see where the bug is but but see
what you're doing we're all staring at
the code right we look at this code
right so actually the promise that
Kerman may not be initialized right and
they ever it may take on some crazy
value and that value is then returned
but what if I cannot look at the data
that I'm using the trainer model
I don't Microsoft may be six years ago
and one of the things I was most
impressed by was how seriously Microsoft
takes data privacy so there's not about
security it's not about people you know
attacking our cloud that is of course
you know p0 that that's absolutely
important but I have never seen a single
piece of customer data even within the
enterprise they're very strong barriers
that I cannot look at somebody else's
data unlesss data as open and shared
right and we have an open and shared
workplace but we extreme
that no engineer can ever long to any
machines you cannot look at any of the
data unless a customer's please Lee
gives us permission for example if this
is in spam email and the customer marks
it like this but they like layers and
layers of protection escalation that
prevent anybody from looking at any data
so we can stare this piece of code
together and look at it and collaborate
and find it find a bug how to do this
with data what are the right tools if
I'm not allowed to look at the data in
addition for what population can I build
a model there's another interesting
question so clearly I cannot build a
model for Microsoft and then use it for
another company because it may leak some
information about Microsoft in that
company but even within Microsoft if I
look at documents documents have
different apples so I might be able to
have access to a document but sue might
not and vice versa so what this means is
that even if I were to build sort of a
model across all the documents the set
of documents that I have access to is
constantly changing so how do I do
machine learning in this kind of an
environment the last thing is actually
is data attacks so there's another very
interesting question namely if we have
this continuous integration pipeline
where basically we collect more data we
update the model the model gets
automatically build and it's automatic
deployed if it passes sort of a certain
set of tests and so on
you can argue well the model gets better
and better and better and they mean you
build some shift into the model that it
sort of forgets all data and only learns
from the most recent data well this is
super this is super Maurice I'm right if
somebody could come in come and I could
go ahead and attack the model with
biased data and then make the model
perform much worse than it did or
discriminate a certain type of
population
so this debugging explaining testing
again interesting I think we have a
bunch of really good engineering tools
on the software module world in sort of
two robots we're getting there
right maybe the most interesting thing
is data and model provenance
maybe a data review process especially
if you look at bias and fairness of data
it would be again be an iterative
process
continuous improvement you know this is
this is sort of one of the big issues as
well that I talked about where he had
this really big cycle there and we have
a lot of tools in software one at all
and so if you know well we're again
starting to learn right we have maybe
data quality engineers maybe we have
ways of detect to respond to changing
input conditions and environmental
conditions right maybe use online and
reinforcement learning maybe we need
something like it did get up for data
like a GBC right we have automail dat
rate of accuracy for speed or memory
footprint the quantization we have
specialized chip so there's a bunch of
work that's actually happening here in
this in the space as well but overall I
think the message amount of land is that
as we have software as engineering
discipline in 1.0 I think we need much
more work to really make the whole
software development cycle the whole
software life cycle to make that an
engineering discipline so with that I
want to call for action and I'm getting
to the end of my talk I know that I'm
between you and a good reception at the
end of the day so we want to collaborate
I think there are lots of really great
open problems here that I think all of
you have a ton of expertise we would
love to collaborate with you there are
many ways of getting resources you know
we announced the Microsoft productivity
research and call for proposals
there's the Microsoft Research open data
actually Microsoft Azure released a VM
data set in 2017 for the SS ppl also the
third most cited ssp paper from s SP to
2017 they just released a new version
and for the faculty summit it's
basically you know 162 million hours of
VMs and resource usage about 1.9 billion
recordings that you can that we can all
use for research analysis and then of
course please send us your students for
internships so with that I hope that we
can do more like the following together
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much